[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord
doyenné
[Musique]
les tendances en prison sans motif
pourtant sans motif
trente maisons comme aux idées sont
prêts à retourner aux idées
c'est le cameroun qui est à la barre se
bat contre personne
on se bat paul aux abois on peut être
contre un gouvernement
reste que son pays
dijon est nécessaire dont je dis que
j'aurais dit que le cameroun doit
continuer à fonctionner nous estimons
qu'on n'aurait jamais dû les arrêter
qu'il était question de l'exercice des
droits reconnus par la constitution
camerounaise qui est exercée par des
camerounais qui ont manifesté certes
mais qui n'avait pas besoin d'être
arrêté
[Musique]